Here with the summary.
As-salamu alaykum.
I got a question. We was uh talking
about hard work. But there are some
people saying smart work is much more
better than hard work.
If we find a smart work, if we find a
way that we can do in a smartest way,
why we want to choose a hard way?
The brother said that if you can do
smart way,
then why do the hard work?
That is number three.
Are the person knowledgeable?
But
if you know the smart way,
for example, you want to do 10 points,
and
you have sought Allah's help,
and maybe you're taking 10 days to do
it.
Now you know the smart way to do it, and
you're able to do it in one day.
So balance nine days, you sleep.
Will you get success?
A person who can do 10 days work in one
day, what does he do?
Allah says for the fun stuff, while I
will be forget.
You strive in Allah's way. The moment
you finish the work, strive again.
So, if you got the smart way, okay, now
I'll relax. Fine, you got it.
You'll only get the 10 points.
You got it?
A person
who reaches and gets the technique
when he realizes, okay, what I could do
in 10 days, I'm doing in 1 day.
Now, might as well I work for 10 days
and get 100 points.
Points is subjective.
It may be in terms of money.
We as Muslims talk in terms of reward.
So, a person who is a very good
businessman, maybe he was working hard
and he was earning maybe $100.
Maybe in 10 days. He realizes if he
changes his job or uses the right
technique, he earns $100 a day.
But then, if he stops at that, he will
not become Bill Gates.
Fine?
You take the life of any successful
person, good or bad.
I have a passion
that whenever I come to know this person
is an expert,
I like spending time with him.
Irrespective, his expertise would be
haram.
Note my point.
Even if he is expert smuggler,
he's working hard.
Allah says, ask the expert. Not that I
want to smuggle.
There is something he has done.
THE UNFORTUNATE PART IS
he's a fool.
He's using that expertise for thing
which is haram.
So, Allah has given each individual
some knowledge,
some expertise,
but they're utilizing in the wrong way.
When people tell me, you quote Quranic
verses. I said, you sing songs very
well. I can't sing songs.
They can sing 100 songs from this movie,
that movie, name of the actor. I cannot.
Allah has given you a memory, but you
want to memorize songs.
You have a memorize. So, if he becomes
an expert in any field,
it's my hobby.
I would like to know what is his
unique point. Irrespective that act is
good or bad.
We are Muslims
who know
the good and evil,
take the expertise,
but utilize it for a good work.
And by Allah's grace, I have met many
experts in different fields, good, bad,
and everything.
I appreciate the admin, this man.
He has been internationally recognized
for something, even if it's bad.
There is something you'll always find.
You name me one person
who's an expert and has not done hard
work.
He has even inherited
wealth from his father, that's it.
He's not an expert.
You meet an expert actor.
The work he's doing is 99.9%
haram. I would yet like to ask him about
why he's What is he doing?
And you'll find that all of them,
almost all, they are hard workers.
The work they may be doing is haram.
Please make a note of that. I'm not
telling you to follow their work.
But, there's something in them that they
have not reached that level
unless
they're dedicated.
They may be dedicated for the wrong
thing.
When you meet the top people,
most of them they sleep less.
4 hours, 5 hours, knowing very well it's
not good for health.
I being a doctor, I know
that minimum 7 hours is required for a
person to sleep.
I know that. Doctors say 6 to 8 hours. 8
hours is correct. 6 is the minimum. The
cardiologists say, "If you sleep less
than 7 hours, chance of you dying is
early."
Alhamdulillah for the past
I think from the age of
maybe 20, from the time I'm doing
medical studies.
For the past 30 years
on average I've been sleeping on average
about 3 hours a day.
Knowing very well
it is medically harmful.
The doctors gave me a warning already
about 5 8 years back
that minimum you have to sleep for 7
hours. Inshallah, I'll try.
But I fear that I'll lose the sawab.
What I'm doing is wrong
but because I'm doing for the cause of
Allah, Allah makes it beneficial.
And normally for giving talks, I always
see to it that I at least sleep longer.
Average 3 hours means sometimes I sleep
for 1 hour, sometimes 4 hours, sometimes
5 hours.
Which is not good. I'm not asking you to
copy me, please.
Even yesterday
yesterday I made a plan at least in this
Dawah training program, at least I'll
sleep for this training program at least
8 hours.
So, previous days I was working hard.
But for it to come on stage day before
yesterday I slept for about 2 hours.
And yesterday again I slept for less
than 3 hours.
It's not good. It's not correct.
But it's striving and it is Allah's
help.
If you're doing it only for the sake of
Allah
for me as far as my life is concerned, I
know that today in the world
there are tens of thousands of Muslims
who have multiple times more knowledge
than me.
I'm not even a drop in the ocean.
I sometimes think
that why do so many people come for the
talk? What is it I've done? I don't have
knowledge.
My knowledge is
less than a drop in the ocean.
If I have to think, the only thing I can
think of
which is not even anything great, then
maybe I strived
a little bit.
Maybe I sacrificed a little bit. What
have I done? Nothing.
And what I sacrificed a drop, Allah gave
me an ocean.
Allah says in the Quran,
you give a loan to Allah, Allah repays a
beautiful loan back to you. 10 times,
100 times, one place Allah says, 700
times. Surah Baqarah chapter 2 verse
number 261. You put one grain in the
cause of Allah subhana wa ta'ala, Allah
subhana wa ta'ala give you seven years.
Each year bearing 100 corns. That means
700 times. In business terminology,
70,000% profit.
I don't know of any business in the
world
which gives you 70,000% profit.
Allah promises.
So, very important, it's striving.
If you know the key,
that fine, you can help 10 people in 10
days.
You realize I can help 10 people in one
day. What do you do? You relax for the
next 9 days?
What difference that make to you?
You get the same.
Or maybe you'll get less.
But Allah gave you the knowledge and now
you're relaxing.
Allah says the moment you finish the
good work, you start again.
If you read Surah Sharh,
Fa idha faraghta fa-nsab. Wa ila rabbika
farghab. And you ask Allah's
forgiveness.
The moment you finished with the good
work, strive again.
A person who's a true moment
keeps on striving
irrespective of the result is.
But Allah promises you that if your
striving is correct, you will get
results.
And the best example in Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam, the means he
had was
nothing. And the result he got today
is mashallah about more than 2 billion
followers, alhamdulillah.
Any questions? Yes, brother.
Assalam alaykum. Wa alaykum assalam wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Now, uh Dr.
Zakir Naik, uh you mentioned that uh the
dedication and you asked us not to
follow your way by sleeping 3 hours or 4
hours. Now, what is the level of
dedication that uh we as a da'ee need to
put in in order for us to reach your
level or maybe like you say that to be
much better than you.
Is it means that like uh when Allah
subhana wa ta'ala says in the Quran that
Nooh alayhis salaam, he call his people
to Islam days and night. So right now we
might have da'ee who are interested to
be full-time da'ee. So they just put
exactly 8 hours and that's it. They just
want to work 9:00 to 5:00, that is 8
hours. So at night is like you can't
contact me. So I'm sleeping at night. So
what is the level of dedication and
commitment that is needed to become a
better and effective da'ee?